- The next round
of Roast Battle is coming up
so we wanted to remind you
why you like watching
comics tear each other
in the first place.
- So we decided to compile
the 10 best burns
from the last
two seasons, enjoy.
- Grrr.
- Tony, the only time you've
ever made a pussy wet is
when you drownd a bag of cats.
- The heat on that burn could
melt armor.
- And it did. He had to bring
that costume back
within an hour.
- Jimmy, you look like you
worked at Hogwarts.
Which is what girls get
when they (bleep) you.
Have you had hogwarts?
- No, but I have fucked Jimmy.
What do Leah and the Armenian
genocide have in common?
They're both too
ugly for America to recognize.
- You might come to a Roast
Battle to see comics
tear into each other
but you stay for the incisive
political commentary.
- You know what that one
brought awareness
to a very important issue also.
- Which is?
Armenian genocide.
- What's so important about
that?
- No fucking clue.
- You look like if Michael Moore
got gang banged by Juggalos.
- I'm just glad Abe Lincoln
was alive to hear that.
- Hasn't Michael Moore
been gang banged Juggalos?
- You know what I think
he's doing
a documentary about that.
- I didn't know much about
Olivia so I went to her website
which is called
"oliviaisfunny.com".
I know.
If she can call
her web website
oliviaisfunny.com
I can call mine
"Todd is really tall
and has a full head of hair dot
com"
- Todd's so easy to roast
that he couldn't resist
doing it to himself at the end
there.
- Todd's been roasting me
my entire career
so... fuck him.
- Nobody will.
- Ms. Pat's pussy is so fat it's
got plates.
And it's like a coal
mine in Chile.
There's 70 people at the bottom
of it
thinking they're gonna
die.
- Oh man I miss
Ralphie. Ralphie May.
Hats off to you buddy roast
in peace.
- You look like MTV2 became a
man.
- See kids, the key to a good
roast joke is specificity.
Who else but Anna
could think of a MTV2 burn.
- Anybody who's ever watched
Celebrity Deathmatch 15 years
ago.
Me.
- Kurt likes to brag that he's
in an open relationship.
And by that he means all the
cases against him
haven't been closed yet.
- The real joke is the idea
that anyone would date Kurt.
- Actually there was so much
sexual tension
during that battle, they were
banging
in the green room afterwards.
- That's why it smelled like
that.
Matt's a lot
like the food at my work.
He's about to get served
by a Mexican.
Matt's never eaten outside
of a country club
so who knows if he even got
that joke.
You're right. Probably didn't
even get it.
- You know, people are asking me
tonight
if I'm going to put Sarah
in her place.
She's a 38 year old woman
in comedy.
There isn't one.
- Fuck, man.
A big shout out
to all the roasters
for not crying on stage.
- Seriously, those were harsh
and the battlers
have set a pretty high bar.
But we promised Season 3
would bring even more heat.
- Grrr.